[Music]
we can personal here 15 I actually came
out and started dating was 17 when I had
my first boyfriend 17 or 18 is 18 I
dated my first and only boyfriend at 19
is I here with now yeah well to this day
what is up with people I'm so happy for
you it was 21 or 22 when we met 22 26 it
was one of those relationships where I
like what didn't tell my parents that it
was happening so they like dropped me
off at this church social and then we
both meet there and then like run across
the streets and like have a date and
then be like I had such a good time at
church tonight thanks mom
[Music]
it's hard to date as a gay man for the
same reason that it's hard today as a
straight woman men suck there's so many
moving parts are you a dominant person
are you submissive person do you think
we go to the gym this much because like
we care about what our bodies look like
well a lot of the people that I've met
want to go to a party and stuff which is
fun and party too but it's different is
it different from straight dating no I
try to forget so many okay so including
my last one one boyfriend one one and a
half for total four and then the one I'm
with currently now I have five I feel
like I've had seven boyfriends in my
lifetime my longest relationship was
eight months which in Gators is like six
years in nine months two years two and a
half years almost a four and a half
years nine years my longest relationship
was actually with a woman
and that was like three years I feel
like it's exactly the same as man dating
a woman and a man dating a man in terms
of like what the relationship is like I
don't think dating a guy is
fundamentally different from dating a
girl it's just a matter of two
personalities and figuring out how you
work together I feel like a relationship
with another guy is challenging because
there's so much thought that goes behind
walking out in public or holding hands
or feeling like you can have some PDA
without getting brassed I think it's
wonderful in a lot of ways I think that
like being with another gay man you have
so much in common and you've grown up
with so many of the same difficulties
that it makes it that much easier to
relate to them on a different level I
don't have a relationship thanks for
reminding me no we both pay we both
clean we both take care of each other
yeah we don't even think of like
traditional generals and my relationship
there's people say who's the girl who's
the guy in a cycle of both guys
relationship I'm actually usually
offended by that question I think when I
was younger I used to hide all my
feminine qualities but now I'm just like
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] you can be
straight and a guy dating a masculine
woman like a tomboy the dynamics are
still kind of the same it's just that
there's two dicks so much did all the
dicks well yeah I want to get married
I've engaged right now
my parents are ruined marriage for me
they are super divorced like a couple
times so I don't ever want to get
married I think it's horrible when I was
younger I thought I was gonna get
married at like 21 or 23 27 originally I
wanted to get married at 29 which would
mean I'd have to get engaged this year
which is not happening I'll be through a
few days before I turned 35 when I get
married my date moved to 35
my ideal marrying age is 35 I don't know
I feel like I'm not in a rush to that
type of commitment
googling engagement rings a lot lately I
think that might be a sign that I want
to get
[Music]
[Music]